[Music]
Saudi Arabia is like no other place on
earth it follows an extreme
interpretation of Islam that many think
has fed the ideology of jihadist groups
such as Islamic state the AL saud rulers
gave their name to the country and rule
as absolute monarchs punishments can be
extreme including death by the sword and
there are harsh curbs on women they must
cover up in public and gender
segregation is common even McDonald's
has a separate eating area for single
men but a revolution has begun
it's led not by people on the streets
but by the king's son
the powerful young Crown Prince Mohammed
bin Salman he's promoting a more
moderate form of Islam he recently
lifted the ban on women driving cinemas
have opened for the first time in
decades and to celebrate the end of Eid
there was even a music festival in
Riyadh
[Music]
so this place this evening is pretty
powerful evidence that Saudi Arabian
society really is changing fast
men and women are mingling freely
concerts about to start fracking it
seems like a pretty ordinary evening of
a kind of Western Fun Fair when I was
here two non half years ago in Saudi
Arabia concerts were forbidden there
were no cinemas and there were certainly
no women driving I'm going on a road
trip to find out what a more moderate
Saudi Arabia would mean for the rest of
the world I remember very well when I
got my driver's license I was 17 almost
18
being able to borrow my parent's car
really did give a sense of freedom I can
just imagine what it must be like for
Saudi women who are driving for the
first time Saudi women are well educated
they account for 60% of university
graduates but strict social conventions
limit their prospects only 20% of women
work compared with 80% of Saudi men this
is nor shebib she was the first Saudi
woman to work as an engineer in oil
drilling today she is driving in Riyadh
for the first time
this is cereal a terrible sense of
direction I'm going to be very dependent
on Google I know I'm very excited in a
country with limited public transport
and a very hot climate cars are
necessities before the ban was lifted
nor had to employ a driver to take her
to work but many Saudi women cannot
afford that luxury for people who
couldn't afford drivers presumably that
means that they can now work in a way
that working was much harder before
being able to drive and having the the
choice to do so will develop women to be
more responsible and mature and
therefore more ready and attractive to
employers to hire so for me Saudi Arabia
has always been somewhat paradoxical in
that it is full of extraordinarily well
educated women and yet it has one of the
lowest rates of female labor
participation in the world that suggests
there's a huge untapped potential in
this country well we'll get there but I
think that the message across the board
has been very positive has been very
encouraging has been very empowering and
so I think it's just the first step on
an excellent path one reason for the
crown prince's social reforms is
economic necessity for decades Saudi
Arabia has been a an oil-rich country
whose people have essentially lived off
the fat of oil revenues more than eighty
percent of government revenue comes from
oil and if you look forward a few years
that's just simply not sustainable oil
prices are volatile and the government
can no longer afford it's wasteful
system of easy public sector jobs mostly
reserved for men and generous benefits
and subsidies one solution is to get
more women into work and that means
easing social restrictions on them but
there is a worrying dark side there
really has been genuine social reform in
this country that this change is very
top-down it's driven by the crown prince
it's driven by the royal family but sad
is that even as this modernization drive
is taking place he has become even more
autocratic and frankly the place has
become more repressive several of the
women who have been campaigning for
greater rights for women were recently
arrested and locked up and we tried for
this film to talk to on camera several
people who have been in the past
critical of the regime and no one wanted
to talk to us arrests and death
sentences have risen sharply under
Prince Mohammed over 60 executions have
been carried out this year alone yet the
prince seems popular especially among
the young in a country where 70 percent
are under 30 but will that last
[Music]
so we're looking at a young generation
who has come back mostly from
scholarships abroad new ideas fresh
ideas and with an understanding of
something that they've learnt abroad
culturally that they would like to see
implemented here hotter alkali sea was
one of the first women to join the Shura
Council which advises the government
what's the most likely thing that could
go wrong frankly speaking I think that
if the aspirations of this younger
generation who have all their hopes in
what we all consider to be a great
leader is their aspirations are not
answered and if they are impatient that
could backlash that's my word
[Music]
the world has every interest in the
success of the crown prince's reforms if
he can show that Saudis can be modern
productive and good Muslims it will help
spread stability in the region and more
moderate Islam across the globe but
Prince Mohammed is making enemies
religious Puritans don't approve of his
social reforms and some Prince's resent
his power grab rumours of Coos swirl
around Riyadh that might explain the
greater political repression and yet
democratic reforms could help they would
allow the prince to use his new
popularity with the young and women to
create a new support base so far though
there's no sign that he will ever go
that far
you